hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast i have the great pleasure today
of sitting with dr lydia mcgrew who is
an expert in philosophical epistemology
which i will ask her to define here in a
moment for those who don't know quite
what that means
lydia welcome to the podcast
thanks for having me brat
so uh before we get to uh the reason for
our conversation why don't you tell us
what epistemology is
epistemology is the theory of knowledge
uh and so it has to do with evidence and
being rational and justified in
believing things and i've worked in
informal epistemology which is sometimes
called classical and then in recent
years formal epistemology where you try
to make uh mathematical models of how
this kind of thing works
excellent and is it fair to say that all
human knowledge is derived from
randomized controlled trials
i would not say that's necessarily fair
um there are a lot of different uh
places where human knowledge comes from
including term definitions um
and
immediate sensation just all kinds of
different sources of knowledge so i
wouldn't say that's true but um some
human knowledge just
well that's a great relief because i've
felt in recent
months that i was going crazy because i
keep being assured that the only way to
know anything is through a randomized
controlled trial and i'm i'm sure that
can't quite be right so anyway you
you have you've reassured me
all right so epistemology is the study
of knowledge and you have worked in both
formal and informal epistemology and for
those who are
perhaps wondering
why anyone would study such a thing i
will just say that this is one of these
fields where most people don't have to
interact with it but ultimately it has
to be properly understood in order for
us to evaluate different kinds of
knowledge and
to understand how how we are to function
uh integrating them for example
so
um i will say i've studied a certain
amount of philosophy of science and
although
it
comes up less often than you might
imagine
in regular conversation the degree to
which the things that are important in
in people's minds depend on the
philosophy of science being rigorously
understood is is quite extreme so
anyway thank you for bringing that to
darkhorse
uh now let's talk about the immediate
reason for our conversation um
you
have had
a
vaccine injury is it fair to say that
yes it is all right and i will say uh i
have
suffered the accusation of being an
anti-vaxxer which is a preposterous
accusation in my on my uh in my case for
a number of reasons i'm one highly
vaccinated against a wide range of
things some of them
rather exotic and two i'm also a big fan
of the idea of vaccination i think it is
incredibly elegant that we can inform
the immune system about pathogens that
we have not encountered and no ancestor
of ours has encountered so that it will
get the jump on those things when we do
encounter them this is a beautiful
system and i in no way am opposed to us
wielding it to the medical benefit of
people or to the epidemiological benefit
of society now i also know you can't
possibly be an anti-vaxxer either
because you wouldn't have a vaccine
injury if you had been one because you
wouldn't have gotten vaccinated is that
a fair characterization
right and also i uh wasn't in any way
required to that's the other thing i
don't work outside the home so i suppose
you could have someone who was an
anti-vaxxer and had their arms twisted
but that wasn't the case i just went out
and decided to do it in my case
yes i very nearly uh
got vaccinated too i
did not because i was concerned that
there were risks that we obviously
couldn't rule out early in the process
and so in effect i was delaying
vaccination in order to know more about
what happened to people who were
vaccinated and the more i heard
the more alarmed i became
but i'm not an anti-vaxxer you're not an
anti-vaxxer and uh
when did you get your your vaccination
april 14th april 14th and which one did
you get it was pfizer um first dose
first dose and did you
have your reaction to the first dose or
did you get a second i only got the
first dose i i had my adverse event in
response to that first dose and
definitely did not want the second one
all right and what was your reaction
so that very night i just i started
getting some allergic
symptoms itching ears and head
and then um within
and then and that was at the same time
as the expected things fatigue and that
sort of thing that everybody thought
within those couple of first days i
started getting nerve pains and
if you've ever had nerve pains they're
very distinctive they're a zinging
feeling and i would get those in
different places in my body
um i was a little worried um
i thought maybe the shingles that i had
had the previous year was coming back
but
it never developed
like shingles over the next couple of
weeks i kept having those i would call
them sort of wandering nerve pains
but i didn't get too worried until about
three weeks later
when it just it revved its zinged way up
to extreme
pain um in my back and my
tailbone and buttocks and legs my legs
started feeling very heavy
um all kinds of things many different
places zinging in my eyes and my face
and
paresthesia in my face and that kind of
thing and um
basically to make a long story short the
doctors are baffled uh i'm just taking
gabapentin for nerve pain at this point
which is not uh therapeutic it's just
for the pain and it's been seven months
and nobody's found any effective
treatment and my symptoms just kind of
go up and down and up and down and up
and down and i have a terrific amount of
pain and nobody seems to have a solution
so i'll keep that i'll keep it that
short um there are other symptoms as
well but i don't want to make the list
too long i do have tinnitus which is
somewhat recognized so maybe some people
will recognize that too just to show the
variety of symptoms involved
yeah i've heard terrifying stories of
tinnitus
beyond
what a human being can tolerate it's
really an incredibly frightening thing i
have a certain amount of uh tinnitus and
i must say most of the time i don't even
realize it's there unless i listen for
it um but a tinnitus that's absolutely
unignorable i've heard comparisons to
and mine is not
my worst symptom but it's you know when
the other symptoms zoom up that kind of
zooms up too so
all right now let's um be cautious here
obviously there is some possibility
that what we have is mere coincidence
that something medically anomalous
happened to you and that the coincidence
in time of it following your vaccination
is not causal but it seems so because
we humans for very easily understood
adaptive reasons are always looking for
connections because very frequently we
find them they are real and we can make
use of them
um
what what can you tell us about the
possibility that what you're dealing
with is an unfortunate medical situation
that doesn't have anything to do with
the vaccination you got
in my in my own case i just i think
that's particularly unlikely for several
reasons first of all my complete
good health right up until i i went in
and we were even joking about things
like oh maybe you're going to grow
another head or whatever you know i mean
i wasn't anxious or anything like that
secondly the fact that the initial
symptoms did come on
along with
the expected symptoms and within that
expected 48 hour um time window when you
do expect to get um
side effects and everybody expects to
get side effects and then it seemed to
grow
out of that and then thirdly what i
imagine we'll we'll talk about more
which is the similarity to other side
effects that i have only subsequently
learned about that other people have had
so uh all right what was your experience
um in terms you know so you had this
event you got a vaccination that you
believed was
uh safe enough to be
uh worth taking and uh effective enough
it's something we both agree is
dangerous coveted
um that you went and got it and then you
started having reactions some of them
within the range of normal
many of them not within the range of
normal and alarming what did you do next
uh you go to doctor after doctor after
doctor yeah i got in touch with my
primary care doctor i kept her you know
very informed she was very concerned at
first she urged me to get the second
vaccine but when um things got bad
enough she kind of stopped you know
pushing that um you research you get
online you google you try to figure out
what to do i kept
you know a lot of records of my symptoms
uh especially in like my my messages on
the uh the my chart portal to my doctor
oh this new thing has happened this new
thing has happened um also we tried um
we tried
valtrex which is a anti-viral medication
in case it was
uh
shingles coming back and so we tried to
get right on that that didn't help
and then the other thing we tried was
prednisone
which is an anti-inflammatory pretty
standard anti-inflammatory that didn't
seem to be helping and then later i had
a second round of that at a much higher
dose that actually seemed to make
matters worse for reasons unknown so you
know we did try some reasonable things
and after that all you can do is keep
making appointments with new specialists
to see if they'll have any additional
ideas
was there agreement amongst the doctors
that you saw that what you were dealing
with was a reaction to the
vaccine um
my my pcp seemed to think so she and i
both at first thought maybe it was the
shingles because we had heard of
shingles being uh that was like a known
thing that sometimes it brought it back
up but then when there were no lesions
and it didn't stay in one place on one
side of the body then we weren't sure
what to do the um first
immunologist i saw
immediately agreed that it was and in
fact he said verbally to me
this is why we usually test these
for two to three years because of
autoimmune disorders that can arise um
i've had one neurologist also say it i i
found that other other doctors will tend
to just record that that's what i said
and not necessarily give me a strong
opinion
one way or another i mean i've been
lucky that nobody said you're totally
crazy um but i don't want to say that
they've all just spontaneously happily
agreed that it's what it is i think
there's a certain amount of caution
all right um
you had an immunologist tell you that uh
as he saw it this did appear to be a
reaction
to the vaccine i will say one of the
things that alarmed me was that given
that we couldn't possibly have had any
information on the long-term effects of
these things that we were portraying
them as safe which anything that
interacts with the immune system
and for which we don't have any
long-term information about what has
happened to people who've taken it can't
really be safe because it's whole
purpose is to modify
this fundamental system and you know we
have
allergic disorders we have autoimmunity
there are many ways in which that system
can be disrupted in a very negative way
so anyway interesting to hear that an
immunologist
saw this as
quite uh quite likely to be causal
all right
so in addition to the doctors that you
saw
did you encounter others who
had similar stories so at first i i
didn't
you know i i thought of myself as kind
of a unicorn and my family of course you
know all believe me they were appalled
but um other immediate members of my
family didn't have a problem so i kept
hearing you know safe safe safe rare
rare rare so i thought well i guess i
must just be one of those really really
rare things
um and i forget what first prompted me
to
be it was just in all the googling i was
doing i came across the story of a girl
a young girl named maddie d guerrae
um who is
now 13 she was 12 she was in the pfizer
trial for 12 to 15 year olds now she is
in a wheelchair but
various of her symptoms
were similar enough to mine only more
extreme
that i said oh
you know maybe there are more people out
there so i began uh looking a little
further and eventually got uh connected
with a couple of facebook groups that
are uh you know documenting these things
and bringing people together who all
claim to have been uh
vaccine injured by these vaccines and i
was just i was just astounded
by the the similarity
so let's let's let's come back to that
in a second i do want to point out a
couple of things about uh the maddie de
gray
story that are that are worth mentioning
first off
she's very severely injured she's in a
wheelchair i think you said as far as we
know she will require one for the rest
of her life she's also on a feeding tube
this is a previously healthy
child
in the trial itself my understanding
is that her
symptoms caused them to quote unquote
unblind the study that is to reveal that
she got the vaccine rather than the
placebo
immediately ostensibly so that she could
be
properly treated but what this did
was it had effects again this is my
understanding from others it had effects
on the continuing of the collection of
data so she was recorded as having had
stomach upset
when in fact she is crippled and now
requiring of a feeding tube and
uh and a wheelchair and so in some sense
this is yes an anecdote it's one
individual and again there is a remote
possibility that something simply
coincidental could explain this on the
other hand healthy children don't
suddenly end up in wheelchairs and
needing field to feeding tubes very
frequently this is an extremely
rare event and when we say well the
trials showed these things to be safe
that depends on the trials having been
well done it depends on things like us
continuing to track people whose story
does not suggest that they had a smooth
ride and maddie diego ray's case says
exactly the opposite it says that there
are things that we should know that are
not widely known
all right now you said you
found
a facebook group or several a couple a
couple of them i was going to mention
too that if you look up that pfizer 12
to 15 uh year old trial
you will not find it easy to to find it
mentioned that there was even a single
child
who had an adverse event this extreme
and adverse events don't have to be
designated necessarily as causal they're
just supposed to be recorded when you do
a trial you just record your adverse
events among the test group and your
adverse events among the placebo group
and then the idea is you know you
compare and see if there's a
statistically significant difference uh
you're not supposed to just make up your
mind ahead of time well this wasn't
caused so we're not going to talk to
people about it and i actually had
someone whom i mentioned maddie who went
and she went and looked it up and she
said well i wonder if her parents are
just completely faking this because i
can't find any mention of this uh in the
pfizer trial and i'm like well that's
pretty creepy you know because if
nothing else
there's nobody who's questioning that
she was in the pfizer trial right and so
you should at least be able to find it
mentioned somewhere other than fox news
that there was a child who was in the
pfizer trial and these events happened
while she was in the pfizer trial right
so it's really striking this gets to
questions of epistemology because at
some level let's let's
give
i won't even call it the benefit of the
doubt because i think it stretches a
good bit beyond that but let's bend over
backwards to imagine that this is
actually not a meaningful event in some
way
all right
it is still important that one child
had a serious medical mishap
shortly after being vaccinated even if
these things were unconnected it is
important that that data point land
correctly so that we can begin to detect
a pattern should it emerge
if what we do is we behave in such a way
that that data point
vanishes and i you know she's not really
an anecdote she was a data point she was
in the trial it's in the trial that's
how you do trials to the extent that
that data point doesn't show up because
it was recorded early as a
stomach upset maybe at the point that it
plausibly was but then it developed into
a crippling injury and that happened oh
yes after the trial had been unblinded
that is no reason not to maintain that
piece of evidence so that we can look at
it later if others who were in the trial
for example show up with a similar set
of symptoms if we disappear that data
point even if we think we're doing the
right thing we have made it impossible
for us to recover the pattern later
should we need to
all right so
you found several facebook groups
uh
who was in them what were they like
well so the largest one has as of now
over a thousand and a half people
and people can only join if they present
to the moderators a story indicating
that they either believe they were
vaccine injured by one of these or
that a family member that they're acting
on behalf of was
and um they're very careful they will
not allow any uh general anti-vaxx
sentiment to be expressed i mean it's
like that's not what we're here for
we're here to share our anecdotes we're
here to like talk about what helped what
didn't help what doctors we've been to
and that kind of thing um so they're
actually trying to be very very careful
about that
and what i discovered and was just
astonished by is that there is all of
this similarity to my own experience
only it's also
varied
so for example one person's
terrible pain might be in the feet
i have some neuropathy in my feet but
that's not where my terrible pain is or
somebody else's terrible pain might be
in that you know like headaches horrible
horrible headaches or something like
that or their whole arms might be
terribly burning um so there's this
variation but the similarity is uh
neuropathy and a lot of it is is
connected to the nerves some kind of
neuropathic uh apparent connection that
really struck me because i knew i had
recorded my symptoms independently
i knew i wasn't coming in here and
saying this because they were saying it
i had said it already and then i found
them
saying it now i should mention that one
of my one of my articles that was
published several years ago uh in fact
several of them have had to do with the
question of independence and witness
testimony
so when you're interviewing people
who've seen a car accident or whatever
how do you know if they've contaminated
each other's testimony if they're
copying or colluding even deliberately
colluding and so one of the things that
you look for is um a substantial
agreement with circumstantial variety
similarity but with variety and so that
was what i was finding here because that
indicates independence i was very very
struck by that uh that in these groups
where these people they come from all
over the world they come from different
parts of the country they had different
shots let me also mention they didn't
all just have one shot we were getting
the substantial agreement with
circumstantial variety
right so this is actually a very
powerful kind of evidence because
it is of course plausible that people
could talk themselves into believing
that they had symptoms from hearing what
others had and if any of those symptoms
are in any way subjective then you could
imagine a group of people suddenly
reporting the same illness and it not
being physiological in nature on the
other hand you had an experience where
you had written down your symptoms not
realizing that there were lots of people
having symptoms so you had a list that
was independent and then you found there
were others and then you compared notes
and those notes had a lot of overlap and
then a bunch of variation as you point
out lots of people have pain but it's
not always in the same place that's not
people copying each other that's people
reporting what they're experiencing
right the other thing i want to note
about independence that the moderators
don't necessarily like on the group but
that i find useful as an epistemologist
people will come newly into the group
and not search the archives
and they'll say thanks for the ad on
this many months past my vaccination has
anyone had
this symptom
and i don't think anybody could fake
that to come in i'm going to pretend i
didn't you know read the read the
archives no you know and so they're
listing it and the rest of us are
sitting there like yeah literally
hundreds of this
had this symptom i don't want to
discourage you but it's not going to
stop anytime soon you know um i'm like
oh my god you know my arms are burning
or whatever you know and so you can tell
that those people are independent as
well because they're coming in they're
brand new and they just didn't bother to
read the archives and they're reporting
a symptom
right now i must say it is also
interesting
a piece of evidence here and again i'm
not saying i know
how one should categorize it but i know
that in my life
a large number of people
have had some serious event
in fact you and i are not independent of
each other although you and i had not
met until we had a preliminary
conversation last week it happens that i
have known your daughter online for
years we've interacted on twitter
and i've met your husband at a
conference so we are not very
far apart and yet you are
yet another person who is a degree or
two of separation from me who is
reporting hey i thought the vaccine was
a good idea i got vaccinated and lo and
behold you never guess what happened but
i had the following experience some of
those people have gotten better some of
them are dealing with continuing issues
as you are but it's an it's an alarming
number of people given what must be a
pool of a few hundred people in
connection to me so
um in any case uh all right i know from
others who have contacted me for whom i
do not have a prior connection and
therefore i have to be a little bit more
skeptical about what i'm hearing because
you know to the extent that
there are people out there who are
i don't know
well they might have an agenda or i can
imagine people being uh
hypochondriacal and
hearing that this thing is out there and
convincing themselves so you know i am
i'm skeptical when people approach me
but i know as i've talked to many such
people they've been in the facebook
groups um they've been to doctor after
doctor some of them have been told this
is in your mind um even though their
symptoms do appear to line up in the way
that you're you're suggesting but i also
know that there's been
um some
tech skullduggery
surrounding these groups that groups
that existed where people had gathered
to talk about what was happening to them
to pool information to figure out if
anybody had discovered anything useful
to do to get rid of symptoms had
discovered doctors who were
productively treating these things
were facebook groups disbanded
yeah i've heard of that too it hasn't
happened since i've been part of it um
but the moderators are constantly
carefully moderating and telling us you
know be careful what you say here
because of course you could get even if
i may just say so a mole also the the
the robots are constantly
reading uh the posts and popping up you
know
code vaccines are safe you know etc if
anybody uses the the v word and so you
know just we we have to be careful and
and even at backup groups on other
platforms if if these were to get shut
down where we could re-gather
all right now
what i would most like to do
as a scientist and a theorist i
frequently encounter people who will
tell me that you know they will say with
a a a glimmer in their eye that the
plural of anecdote is not data right now
i also know that at some level the word
anecdote is
misused by people it's mu it's used
effectively
to
dismiss a piece of evidence rather than
allow it to be integrated at a natural
level and it is certainly the case that
a single anecdote is not a pattern in
and of itself
but it is a kind of evidence and the
trick the way one figures out whether
there is a pattern does initially
involve looking at anecdotes you can't
look at data because data only exists
after you have set out to collect it
what causes you to set out to collect it
are
patterns that one informally notices
which actually are the first step in the
scientific method observation
involves looking at patterns and saying
i wonder why this is true
here's a possible explanation and if
this possible explanation was correct
these other things repeat would be true
and then i can go look for those other
things and see if they are in fact
present right observation hypothesis
prediction test that's the method
so when people say
they roll their eyes at the idea that an
anecdote has caught your attention what
they are really doing is interrupting
the first step in the scientific method
and i would point out that yes it is
true that it is preferable
when one has anecdotes that are
suggestive of a pattern right anecdotes
say people collected in a facebook group
reporting symptoms that are not
identical but are suggestive of some
sort of underlying pathology that that
should cause
rigorous tests to be done
that's what one wants to happen
but when there is resistance to running
those tests when there is resistance to
analyzing the evidence that has
accumulated then we are left with the
anecdotes not by choice but that's
simply what is present for us to
evaluate and so there's something
i would say diabolical
about
claiming that something is safe
and then ignoring evidence that it might
not be so safe and then chastising those
who are looking at the evidence that
exists the anecdotes and saying you
don't have a right to do that because
anecdotes aren't science right that's
all nonsense
have i misdescribed any of this no i
think i think that's accurate i mean i
think it was charles sanders purse who
said do not block the course of inquiry
and um that's that's what's happening
here is the course of inquiries being
blocked actually there have been quite a
number of published case studies and so
this is interesting because high level
medical journals do publish single case
studies or a case study of three
individuals or seven individuals or that
kind of thing i could send you links to
published case studies of a parent
you know severe adverse events after
these covet vaccines some of them
neurological in nature um so it isn't
even true to say that no respectable
journal will publish something except
for a large you know uh
blinded trial or something like that
that's not true they publish case
studies all the time and then after the
case studies come in then they might go
out and gather more um another thing
that i would want to mention would be
that testimony is always going to be
important
um even if a scientist does a study
you're going to be dependent on the
scientist's testimony that i mean if he
he could lie there is such a thing as
scientific fraud
so
ultimately we're going to be dependent
on testimony unless you want to get
deeper down to you know sense data or
something really underlying but uh you
know testimonies at a pretty fundamental
level epistemologically
moreover when you do
even larger scientific studies you're
going to be using to some extent
anecdotal information as far as like
does the patient say that this symptom
has resolved i've been reading a lot
more scientific papers than i ever you
know had before medical papers in
researching this and you'll find you
know the researchers will say okay that
um the patient said
that they had experienced such and such
such and such many patients that they
experience such and such degree of
resolution in their pain
for whatever
whatever the medication might be to find
out if a medication is effective so
they're taking that the word for it of
those patients and recording it so in
that sense anecdotes are feeding into
scientific investigation even the most
formal kind of scientific investigation
at multiple different levels yes it's
absolutely maddening to me as somebody
who practices science that we would
dismiss anecdote right if i don't have
those anecdotal patterns to work from in
order to figure out what hypothesis
might be worth testing
then there's no way to start and it
occurs to me even just talking to you
right now
that we have
medicine functioning at different levels
right we have public health
and we have
you know
official guidance on what drugs work on
which conditions and things like this
but the practice of medicine that takes
place in a doctor's office
is in fact supposed to be about the
doctor's ability to work from anecdote
and figure out what it suggests about
what you likely have
what things tend to work for people who
have similar types of diseases doctors
are actually supposed to test hypotheses
at a level that isn't formal
right they're supposed to say well gee
that sounds like you might have a
problem a generalized inflammation
problem if they're a good doctor they
might say let's figure out what's
causing the inflammation a regular
doctor might say let's treat the
inflammation you know
but in any case the point is doctors are
not running studies on
large numbers of patients in general
they are working with individuals whose
presentation is um
individual in it by its very nature
and when they do it right they end up
alleviating symptoms and treating
disorders in a in a way that's effective
so
at some level i feel like we are being
um
we are being fed
epistemological nonsense so that we will
not be able to recognize a pattern that
is obvious in front of us yes well and
the doctor himself might then use
induction uh you know doctors will say
to me i had a patient who you know i
don't know how many times you've heard a
doctor say that oh yeah i've had
patients who i had a patient who and so
then that will lead a doctor to maybe
use a medication more often because it's
worked on his patients so doctors are
doing informal science like that all the
time and just in their own practices
absolutely and i would also you know i i
think i mentioned it earlier but
we also have
systems set up so that we are not left
with anecdotal evidence we have the
vares system in the u.s for example
which is supposed to capture adverse
events following vaccination and should
there be a pattern it doesn't mean that
every instance that shows up in the very
system will be caused by a vaccine but
if we simply record every time somebody
has had a
serious medical incident in close
proximity to a vaccination event if we
collect all of that evidence we'll be
able to say hey look if there is nothing
with these vaccines
then the rate at which people have let's
say a heart attack following this
vaccination shouldn't be any different
than the rate at which they have a heart
attack following
the flu vaccine and if the rate is
10 times 50 times higher then you say
well huh i wonder why these two groups
of people who got a vaccination and then
went home and
had their event why are these two groups
so different
so
what i'm constantly told
is that the vare system
is unreliable and therefore that the
huge spike in adverse events following
the covet vaccines is not meaningful
but nobody seems to know
what that implies they seem to think
that implies that these things are safe
which it doesn't at best it implies that
we don't know how safe they are and it
is odd that they suddenly decided that
it was unreliable this year
it was it was it was strangely reliable
through 2020 through you know or you
know 2019 let's say through flu season
pre-covered the vera system was
considered reliable and oddly enough
when 2021 came around and we rolled out
the covet 19 vaccines it became abruptly
unreliable um i don't know how that
happened or to put it differently uh
previously it was regarded if anything
as uh needing to be multiplied by a
multiplying factor so if it was
unreliable in any way it was by under
reporting rather than by over reporting
now suddenly we're supposed to believe
it's vastly over reported and i don't
know why we should be so confident of
that right we can't possibly be
confident of that but i guess i would
say again
i don't want to give the benefit of the
doubt because i don't believe it is a
reasonable doubt but if we bend over
backwards
to grant everything that those who claim
these vaccines are safe
want us to believe at best we've got a
system that doesn't tell us how safe
they are it certainly doesn't tell us
that there's no problem that they are
safe right and let me also add that the
pop-up you get on facebook or any of the
these other places will say and are
continuing to be monitored for safety so
it won't just say that they're safe
it'll say and they're being carefully
monitored and i'm going
where is this happening where is this
continuing monitoring happening if not
through vares is there some secret
system that they're using to being
continually monitoring no obviously the
vare system was supposed to be that
system right and so that part of the
that part of it should be deleted in any
event if they're now going to say that
that system has no monitoring capability
because it's some wildly unreliable the
other place you could monitor it is you
could continue to monitor the level of
events in the control group of the
initial safety trial versus the
treatment group but they didn't allow
that either my understanding is that
they
treated everybody
after the short initial test period so
there is no remaining control group so
again we have a system that for whatever
reason
is incapable of delivering us a signal
that these vaccines are dangerous even
if they are and so what we are left with
is a world of anecdotes that we are told
we must ignore which epistemologically
does not make any sense
and
uh it must be driving you crazy as an
epistemologist to be
in the group that is uh held at the
level of anecdote and then
to watch the conversation continue as if
nothing abnormal is taking place
right and then um
when you would be willing to be studied
and you're not being contacted to be
studied i mean not just me but others
would make our medical information if
someone wanted to do like a
retrospective study or something like
that it's like fine you know if you
would like to turn us into data we are
only too happy to be turned into data
and and there's uh so far quite a lack
of interest in that
so to fill that in and i you know i
think most people probably will figure
it out on their own but were you to find
yourself in this group
you have taken a vaccine
something has happened to your life you
discovered there are many others you
don't know whether you're stuck with
these symptoms permanently whether they
will clear up on their own whether
you're stuck with them except if a
treatment is found and hopefully it will
be and so of course you want to be
studied
the amount of good that would come from
understanding what has happened to you
is potentially huge and the benefit of
it would go to you so
there's no it's there's no mystery that
there are lots of people waiting to have
somebody say all right i'm sick of being
an anecdote let's turn me into data
figure out what's going on so we can
help the others who have the same
condition right and yet
it doesn't happen
it's it's not happening and
partly i want to be as fair as i can and
say well it's still maybe early days
maybe it will happen soon
i don't know what to say i don't know to
what extent and as i say i could send
you links to individual case studies so
those guys who did those they're out
there doing this
um
but
i'm not terribly hopeful i'm not
terribly sanguine because i do think
there's a there is a disincentive um
there was one um
one doctor who put it in my chart that i
said this happened after the vaccine but
he didn't say that he thought it but he
said it
verbally to me and so that was
interesting to me so one of the
immunologists he put it into his notes
you know i believe this is an
autoimmune thing but the the neurologist
just recorded what i had said
but verbally he said to me that he
believed this was caused by the vaccine
so i do think there is nervousness i do
think there is there is worriness in the
medical
uh community about
and and possibly in the research
community as well i'd be interested to
hear some anecdotes from uh
medical researchers who are a little
different from necessarily the doctors
with boots on the ground as to whether
they think that this is uh dangerous to
them if they were to publish studies of
that i don't know the answer to that
question
yeah there's uh there's a question about
the formal danger to people's careers
and then there's a
lower level of coercion where people are
socially concerned of what happens if
they acknowledge a hazard and i will
point out
if you look at what's happening to eric
clapton
there is a very clear message
here we have a person i mean his
nickname is slow hand right this is a
person
who is famous for what he does with his
hands
he found himself unable to do what he
has done in life following a vaccination
again he can't be an anti-vaxxer he took
the vaccine willingly was injured and
let's say that he was the only person on
earth who had this or let's say that it
was a
pure coincidence and not causal somehow
still how
unkind is it to not allow a human being
to discuss his own experience and
experience that any of the rest of us in
his shoes would be saying the same thing
i feel like this vaccine caused this
problem with my
you know my hands the way that my
right ruin my life
and so i guess the point is i'm watching
him
uh
stigmatized publicly as if he is somehow
the culprit
right when at worst
he has drawn a connection that doesn't
deserve to be drawn and more likely
actually he's suffered an injury and
he's entitled to talk about it it just
seems to me so cruel
that society would take a position that
those who have had an experience must be
silent about it
um for fear that it will cause other
people to worry about something which
they should probably worry about right
exactly it should be possible to say you
you know
you should be a little more worried
about that i'm perfectly open to saying
yeah i think people should be more
worried about this i suggest today read
an article uh from australia i don't
remember the name of the person and i
think it was yeah it was a heart attack
i think he had her no maybe it was uh no
maybe it was just myocarditis anyway it
was a heart inflammation and uh
he was interviewed and they let him tell
his story and it went into the news but
he had to say over and over and over
again in the story i'm not trying to
make anybody vaccine hesitant i'm not
it's not my goal to make anyone hesitant
about getting the vaccine here in
australia and then he would go but at
the same time i do think this should be
studied more you know etc etc and and he
he was having trouble getting his thing
reported to the australian version of
theirs he had to do it himself but he
believed that if his doctor did it it
would have more um i don't know it would
be taken more seriously or whatever and
the doctor said i'm too busy you get
online and do it type thing and uh and
so even the the person writing the
articles seemed to accept that it had
been caused but kept saying rare rare
rare over and over again you know um but
it bothered me there was something very
propagandistic about the fact that this
man could only get his story told if he
said about five times i'm not trying to
make anybody vaccine hesitant well what
the heck he should be allowed to say man
i think maybe people should be more
hesitant about this and you still ought
to tell a story it's an interesting
story
well i also i almost feel like this is
an epistemological crime i i don't know
if that's a category but i think the
point is a human being is not built for
a world of formal science a human being
is a brilliant creature that is capable
of taking information some of that
information will appear meaningful and
turn out not to be right but a human
being is a human being needs to be able
to say look
my friend group
went and got vaccinated and there wasn't
an incident among them but you can't say
that if somebody who had had an incident
would have to think twice about speaking
publicly about it or they would have a
social catastrophe on their hands right
so the point is you don't know it seems
like the events are rare
but the rarity may in par you know how
many people have been effectively
silenced watching what's happening to
eric clapton and saying you know what
it's not worth it i'm not simply not
making uh the connection
that is true as well um i watched an
interview with the lady her first name
is deborah she was a physician's
assistant you probably know the
interview i'm talking about anyway she
was um told by her fellow medical
practitioners you filed the various
reports we're too busy there are too
many of them etc even though they were
sufficiently important that they were
actually required by law to do it but
they let her do it for them for a while
and then they said no just do it on your
own patience um anyway
she
was um oh man i forgot where i'm going
going with this but oh i know what it
was she was saying that she had a
colleague an oncologist who took to
asking his patients
have you been vaccinated
so when their cancer was coming back out
of remission her colleague
was noticing the connection and the
patients were not
so i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you an
anecdote i'm gonna blind it a little bit
here because this person hasn't given me
permission but i was talking to someone
about my own experience and she said to
me and this was a medical person in the
medical field and she said to me oh it's
so interesting that you you had the
vaccine and you had this happen that's
odd i am
i had this thing where i was in terrible
pain and i was also i was out in the sun
and i almost anaful acted with a
temperature reaction and so forth and
then i woke up in the middle of the
night i was screaming in pain
and uh she said but i do think the
vaccine is safe
so she had made no connection whatsoever
until she heard my story and she's a
medical person
so i think it is underreported and i
think one reason is what you're saying
people are afraid of social ostracism um
so we can't make that argument arguments
from silence kind of stink anyway but
but we can't make that argument from
silence i haven't heard anybody say
anything so it must not have happened in
my friend group that's very weak
argument but also because i think there
are cases where there is a plausible
connection but people are not making it
because they're as we say the prior
their prior is so low and so when their
prior is really low then they're they're
not going to make that connection
right now
i of course haven't a clue what we are
supposed to
to do
with this right what ends up happening
is those of us who have
i guess accepted the price of
talking about our
negative experiences or our skepticism
our alarm our inability to look away
from the evidence that's accumulated in
the vares system or the yellow card
system
right we we have elected to pay a price
and so or
we have refused to dodge that price i
guess
and
we talked to each other and so that is
liable to be distorting in a sense right
when you find that you've got a group of
people who has already paid the price
and are
interacting and then you have another
group that isn't paying the price that
is surrounded by a great deal of silence
on the matter also not getting a clear
picture and of course
i think the problem is
i've said this in other contexts that
science is a very beautiful
and powerful process but it is also a
fragile process that it depends on
certain conditions being met and it is
not
capable it is not capable of overcoming
something like a propaganda campaign
that keeps evidence from emerging to a
place where we can evaluate it
and so
i don't you know i've been stigmatized
as all sorts of things including
uh an anti-vaxxer
and
i cannot seem to break through the wall
of people who need to be thinking about
why it is that people like you and i
would end up in this very
unpleasant situation of talking publicly
about something that powerful forces do
not want disgust now i know or just or
just blowing my own privacy
like right how many people want to go
out there you know i'm lucky right
my husband supports me all right you
know so i don't think he's going to lose
his job because i came out and did this
you know so i'm not going to be
penalized nearly even as much as you
have
but who wants to go out there and tell
people i have horrible tailbone pain you
know i mean it's usually something you
keep private it took me months to agree
to pay you know even that much of a
price but but you're right you know we
we don't want to be in in a bubble uh
and richard feynman the great physicist
said that science demands a particular
kind of honesty which is that you're
willing to bend over backwards to um
bring in things that might possibly be
contrary to to your own view you know he
was funny since i don't care if you lie
to your girlfriend but you when you're a
scientist you don't lie as a scientist
and and so that's that fragility i think
he in a sense sense that fragility that
you're talking about there and i'm not
sure what's going to happen but i do
fear that signal is being broken as you
say and public trust is certainly eroded
and the proceeding of science at least
in things surrounding covid is being
broken in
the world as a whole i was going to say
the united states but other countries
too
yeah other countries too in fact
absolutely terrible stories coming out
of
australia i interviewed
a woman who has terrible immunological
sensitivities
including
anaphylactic
shock as a result of exposure
to polyethylene glycol which is in two
of the vaccines and a close relative is
in the third to which she has
access and she's being told she should
be vaccinated anyway she just should
simply get vaccinated in a hospital
where they can rescue her after she has
her anaphylaxis which
is a medically nonsensical position in
light of
the fact that this disease
uh as bad as it is is not smallpox
it's
also rare in australia so the chances
that anyone is actually protected from
covet itself by her being vaccinated
makes no sense and
frankly many people who
were reluctant about vaccination and
were vaccinated anyway were vaccinated
on the basis that we needed to protect
the vulnerable and if she's not the
vulnerable then who is right right
exactly and and now we're hearing that
myocarditis in children is mild
so
we should be willing to send the
children out there vaccinate a bunch of
little kids and if they get myocarditis
hey it'll probably be mild never mind
the fact that covet would probably be
mild if they got coveted
so this is crazy covid would be mild as
far as we know myocarditis the idea that
this is a mild condition
is preposterous the idea that you would
imagine that it is likely to be mild in
children where they have a very long
life ahead of them in which bad things
can happen
right you would even take that risk
right there's no medical justification
at best the justification when it comes
to children is that it will protect the
old and infirm but we as a society have
never had the conversation where we say
it's acceptable to rob young people of
health to protect the old and infirm and
i think frankly only a sick society
would ever make such a choice
ethically horrible
right it's ethically indefensible in my
opinion and so yes we are not we're not
having that uh that conversation we're
also
not
um
the other side is not planned fair
right heather and i were very clear
before there was evidence
of uh
myocarditis being uh
a frequent
i don't mean frequent in terms of the
number of people who have it but
frequent among the um the adverse events
we were alarmed that there was a danger
of hazards that we didn't know about yet
and that we should be cautious for that
reason and now of course how many people
have learned the term myocarditis
because it is well understood to be
caused by these vaccines where is the
acknowledgement that in fact our caution
was well placed right right right right
you know you predict things well and and
you can see that the
the propaganda machine is getting out
ahead of it so the very fact that we're
now being told myocarditis in children
is usually mild they can treat it with
you know advil at home or whatever what
is that it's it's preliminary propaganda
it's it's a prophylactic propaganda
you might say so that if people say i
told you so here now we've got a bunch
more you know pericarditis and
myocarditis cases among children there
wouldn't be before they they're like
yeah we already knew that would happen
we told you it would be fine and not
many very many of them are dying so stop
worrying about it so basically nothing
is going to be allowed to to shake this
it's a certain view of what should be
done and that view is not going to
change i i fear yeah it's it's the
ultimate epistemological sin which is to
start with your conclusion and work
backwards from it and force the evidence
to fit it no matter what the evidence
suggests
and
my husband likes to use the metaphor of
the pink panther if i recall correctly
and he's used this for years and that in
the introduction he would have a little
hole and he would go down the hole if
you've ever seen the cartoon and then he
would pull the hole
behind him
and that it would disappear
so he's
he's in there he's locked down in there
and that that's what's happening we're
doing the pink panther yeah it's a kind
of uh hermetically sealing a perspective
so that whatever evidence there is can't
uh can't alter it um that that is what
appears to be happening and there's just
simply nothing apparently that can
derail the strain which is the most
frightening thing of all
right if you had the sense that the
medical authorities
were grappling with the evidence and
that they were actually balancing the
question of the
harms of covid the deaths that will
arise from people getting sick with this
infection that we have not successfully
controlled and that they were balancing
that with the potential harm to people
from being vaccinated to prevent the
disease
well then there's a lot of discussion we
can have we under you know adults can
understand that this vaccine doesn't
have to be
uh completely safe in order to be
worthwhile but what one gets the sense
is that we've just sort of
definitionally decided it's safe and
that it has nothing to do with evidence
and that evidence you know will be
uh dismissed if it arises as it has
i think that's because if we had that
conversation there might be some
recognition that a free people should be
permitted as adults to make that
decision for themselves and for the
vulnerable children or
others who are not
legally responsible for whom they are
legally responsible and that's what must
not be
allowed to happen is to allow freedom of
choice on this issue well so i i'm i'm
betting you and i are going to end up in
a different place here not meaningfully
in the current circumstance
i believe it is conceivable that one can
imagine a pathogen
and a vaccine
and
a
an epidemiological pattern
in which coercion might be necessary
for the benefit of civilization
i don't believe that that is remotely
happened in this case not this disease
not these vaccines and not these
authorities
none of these things justify that
coercion but as an abstract question i
believe such an event could happen so
i'm hesitant to say that this is an
issue of free choice because although i
believe it should be that in this case
it's a ma it should be a matter of free
choice because the medical authorities
are not doing their job they're in
breach of social contract with us that
they have actually made us vulnerable
they have failed to give us good advice
they have failed to use the tools at
their disposal to control the disease
without exposing us to the hazards of
these vaccines and
when it comes to kids
they have demonstrated that they
actually are not bound by any normal
ethical calculation
right or or cost benefit and there
that's the whole question is cost cost
benefit and utilities and all of that
all of that kind of thing yeah i mean i
i i would take the position that it
shouldn't you know it shouldn't ever be
coerced but you know a year or two ago
maybe i would have been where you are
and i think that the
watching it in real time
has gotten me to the point where i'm
just like yep even if it's
even if it's bubonic plague and we have
a safe vaccine and i think it's and this
takes us into of course political
political philosophy which is not even
my field but um
you know the sort of power corrupts and
absolute power corrupts absolutely
issue and so that you know that power to
make you
go out there and get something you know
stuck into your body that's a pretty
it's pretty big power and i think we are
seeing it go go to people's head but
something i think you and i may agree
about
is
a statement that a friend made to me
online
he said people human beings have a great
desire to be ruled by experts and he
clearly didn't think that was a good
thing
and i think that um you and i are both
maybe seeing the concern where that
human desire is you know here here take
take it away from me take this decision
away from me and just rule me for my for
my own good and that is backfiring on us
in a big big way here in this particular
epidemic well let me ask you a question
i i agree with that and my basic sense
is in the current circumstance um
at the point that civilization has
uh failed
to live up to its responsibility to its
citizens where it has put us uh
um
in harm's way and prioritize the
interests of pharma or whatever else
where we are just simply carried along
uh in this dangerous trajectory then yes
we have the right to opt out
on the other hand if let's just take an
extreme case let's say
that a
um
[Music]
a christian scientist family that the
child of a christian scientist family
christian scientists as i understand it
do not believe in medical intervention
let's say that a child from this family
has been bitten by a rabid animal right
right right right now a rabid a bite by
a rabbit animal is likely highly likely
to
cause rabies and once the symptoms of
rabies begin i believe there's only one
case in history where a person has ever
survived
so it is a fatal disease and a terrible
terrible death
in that case
i would be in favor
of
coercing
the use of the vaccine which can save
this child's life
and is comparatively safe as far as i
know i've i've had a rabies vaccine
although not the post-exposure one i've
had the pre-exposure one but nonetheless
in that case i believe coercion would be
justified and freedom of choice would
not trump that choice i think what what
we're up against here is that there is
no getting away from what i believe
aristotle called for nasa's um you know
um which is a kind of
a kind of wisdom
in governance
we're not going to be able to get away
from the need for wisdom in governance
but generally what free societies have
done
is to try to keep those kinds of extreme
scenarios to a minimum
so that they're they're being done on an
individual case-by-case basis i mean
this is for example why uh committal
involuntary committal for insanity for
example is something that's done on an
individual basis with a finding before a
judge and um you know you've got to have
a certain number of expert witnesses and
that kind of thing
because you want to safeguard the
freedom of the individual um and
have generally shied away from giving a
huge amount of power
to a government entity particularly a
government entity that governs a very
large number of people you know millions
and billions even of people um then that
that becomes all that much more
dangerous because
one uh person in that position who's
making very very bad judgment can harm a
whole lot of people and i think that
that is what we're seeing happening here
oh well i agree and i think whatever the
explanation the public health
authorities are effectively
um delivering us to a for-profit entity
that insists that its product is
so good that it must be mandated
and the evidence just simply doesn't
support that conclusion so it's not that
what i'm saying
i just
i i
do not want to represent myself as
believing that personal choice is the
top priority right it's a very high
priority but there are circumstances
that that uh
uh rise to a higher level of
significance i just don't think yeah i
don't think we are remotely there right
right this this is not the disease these
are not the vaccines and these are not
the public health authorities all three
of those things are independently
capable of rendering the coercion
invalid this disease
is dangerous to people with
comorbidities it is a terrible disease
it's damaging but it is not deadly to
most people who contract it
these vaccines are not so safe that it's
a non-issue we have a huge adverse event
signal and nobody chasing it down and
the public health authorities
you know however many months we are now
into this pandemic
still have yet to recommend vitamin d
to energy they've made mistake after
mistake after mistake and they're also
interfering in things like economics
where they have no expertise whatsoever
and that's terrifying i mean something
like ordering a lockdown is not really a
public health
decision alone it's an economic decision
so whoever said that anthony fauci is an
expert in economics
right and you know
it is not in any way clear that a proper
even a proper medical analysis was done
about the net impact of that lockdown
when you take into account things like
um abuse that takes place in a world
where people are disconnected you know
child abuse for example um depression
depression medical checkups for diseases
that are deadly in their own right right
right so yes if for whatever reason
decisions were made like this is a
simple matter of there's one
objective of civilization and it is to
fend off covet which we have
incidentally done a terrible job of
but everything
right but we're willing to crash the
rest of everything to to do that one
thing well that's not none of us signed
up for that right well in a book that i
think is is relevant here is is one of
my favorites is the vision of the
anointed
um by thomas soul and he talks about the
vision of the anointed and the tragic
vision i'm sure i'm not telling you
anything you don't already know but the
vision of the anointed is that there are
solutions
what we're looking for are solutions and
the tragic vision is that there are no
solutions there are trade-offs and
compromises and they're always going to
be trade-offs
what we are seeing in covid and in other
areas as well like inflation and so
forth is the imposition of the vision of
the anointed we're going to solve this
we're going to fix this and it's it's
not solving it first of all but it's
also
causing all of the other problems
because of that solution mindset rather
than trade off and compromise mindset
yeah that's interesting um
the solution mindset is the mindset of a
child
right a child sees the problem and wants
it fixed the adult understands that the
fix has costs too and that the the
benefit has to outweigh those costs and
that one has to integrate into that
calculation something about the unknowns
right and that you know yes if the
benefit is sufficient
to overcome all of the costs that we can
identify and a reasonable estimate of
the costs we cannot identify in advance
then it is worth contemplating but that
doesn't appear to have been done here at
all
and we have to be ready to change course
too if we find that oh man we made a
mistake you know absolutely right so uh
in our book my wife and i advocate for
um the precautionary principle that one
has to look at the potential hazards of
these things
we acknowledge that that's a very
difficult principle to operationalize
well but as a guiding principle the
recognition that solution making always
has unintended consequences and that we
need to be ready for them and then we
need to be able to reverse course right
reversing course is the best protection
we have it's the fail-safe and
it is exactly the opposite of a system
in which having said the word safe and
effective we are just going to simply
declare that that is the fact
irrespective of what evidence may emerge
is um
you know it's like um
it's like philosophy by a five-year-old
right it's it's it's terrifying and it's
um it's an application of the
cost fallacy in a sense we've done all
of this and it'll it'll make it look
like it was all for nothing if we don't
double down
and it's like well you have to be
willing to admit that you were
that you were wrong so
um i'm hoping that by you know telling
my story giving up my privacy i can uh
kind of help people at least to the
extent that it does lie within their
choice and their decision to to think
again and i'm not under any illusions
that any member of government is going
to think again because here's my uh
anecdote or even my walking into as it
were a virtual room full of anecdotes
and my evaluation of that is an
epistemologist
but um you know there might be some
lawmakers here there that can use this
to help them and certainly individuals
who can hopefully uh use it to guide
their own decisions
wow well i must say uh i love the sunk
cost fallacy it's a really important
recognition but i hadn't thought of it
this way that in some sense the large
number of people who you have run into
who appear to have been injured
and are suffering silently because to
pursue a solution to your injury would
be to admit that it exists
that in effect uh it's like um
a class of non-citizens
who exist
because they are the sunk costs uh of of
a policy that we could change that we
could uh accept was an error but um
something is going to insist on having
been right even when it was very wrong
and that's a terrifying place to find
civilization has descended to
it is especially expanding it to
children and you know i hope i hope that
i am wrong as far as the prevalence of
really bad side effects among children i
would love for it to be the case that
just as children don't get coveted as
badly as a lot of adults they maybe will
also not get
side effects as badly as adults i don't
think we can infer the one from the
other at all it doesn't seem to me
medically um so i hope we don't get some
explosion but in a dark way a very dark
way it will be interesting to see what
happens if we start getting a very large
number of anecdotes of
children ages 5 through 11 having
terrible terrible side effects and the
medical establishment saying
i can't hear you or the government
establishment saying i can't hear you
is that going to change anything is
anything going to happen uh to to make
them change course i don't know well
unfortunately i think uh
the maddie de gray story
uh it's a bad sign isn't it it's a it's
an awful sign and i would also say
that no matter what
we are again in the same circumstance
where you can tell
we have no reason to believe that
vaccinating these children is safe it
doesn't mean it will be harmful but it
means that we cannot rule out that it
will be harmful and there are signs that
mean that we should be very concerned
and because healthy children are not
severely harmed by kovid it is a
preposterous it is an evil choice for us
to be making and the fact that
after
ignoring a large group of people who
appears to have been injured by vaccines
that they were told were safe and
effective at seeing that not only has
the have these vaccines failed with
regard to safety but they also have
failed with respect to effectiveness the
fact that we're talking about boosters
being necessary for people
six months down the road this tells us
that safe and effective didn't turn out
to be right and the people who assured
us that that was true either knew better
and lied or they didn't know better and
should have or they were caught by
surprise and now they're going to just
double down and say well then i guess we
just got to do it i guess my point would
be though
it's not doubling down when you add
children to the mix
right that is
ratcheting up that is a new level of
indifference to potential harm
and it will be i fear indifference to
actual harm the other thing that strikes
me and
maybe has a little bit of an echo of the
of communism and i i hesitate to use
this word but you'll see where i'm going
with it in a minute is that
the the d rays were so pro-vax that they
entered three of their children into the
trial maddie volunteered from the story
that i've heard is the two of her
siblings were going to be in the trial
and they apparently were fine
and then she said oh i want to help too
because i want to help to end the
pandemic and her parents were thrilled
to let her do it and then this happened
and her parents are like oh my goodness
this happened to us and the fact that
they were so committed to the system was
not good enough to get them listened to
okay and so i think we find that where
we have people who've been sort of
mugged by reality and they're loudly
they were loudly an affirmation of the
system um
like people who were like you know i'm
i'm a good soviet comrade please listen
to me our food supply system is not
working or whatever i'm trying to help
the party right and and then it was like
we don't want to hear what you're saying
shut up you know so it's the odd thing
is you would maybe have thought that the
depth of commitment that this family had
to
the vaccination efforts even for kovitz
specifically would have won them a
hearing but it did not
it's a terrifying
terrifying point right these are people
who more than did their part
right
and if anyone is deserving of
being
listened to
being treated at the highest possible
level being heralded as a hero i mean if
anybody is a hero of this pandemic this
little girl is she volunteered to test a
vaccine so that panda so the pandemic
could be ended
was injured right this is a this is a
this is a fallen soldier at some level
how dare we how dare we ignore her
that's
it you know
it's a very upsetting point i had not
thought about it that way but
my god
i know i know
it's it's terrible it's really and and i
fear we're gonna see more of it and so i
guess what i'm gonna say to parents for
sure is if you have to homeschool your
kid or whatever you have to do i would
urge them
not to do this
that would be my message that you know
you don't have to take responsibility
for that but that's something that i
would say to parents well i would
certainly say
look at the evidence right right all
right and you're the parent it's you've
got to make a decision here you've got
to make a decision
and the real question is are you the
parent you know i've watched these
public health messages and they
blur this distinction between
getting kids vaccinated to end the
pandemic and getting kids vaccinated to
protect them from covet the second one
of these things does not need to be done
for a healthy child right as far as we
know so
the idea that we're going to just blur
that line and say oh it's good to
vaccinate children when actually it puts
them in harm's way and does not benefit
them in fact it may
actually let's say that the vaccine
works in children the way it works in
adults it may stave off covid they may
get their boosters they may face the
hazards that come along with them until
they're no longer so young that kovit
doesn't threaten them right it's like
uh
we might right right i see what you're
saying so the point is
you as a parent are supposed to do what
is in this child's interest and frankly
you are supposed to tell society that it
does not have the right to take health
from your child to protect others
right you're supposed to say that and if
somebody came to you and said hey you
know what happens that your kid is a
match for my grandmother who needs a
kidney and your kid has two
right so we're just gonna take one your
kid will be fine people live with one
kidney you're supposed to say no i'm
very sorry about what's happened to your
grandmother but no right
this is that situation the fact is
this disease is not one that these kids
need a vaccine to fend off and these
vaccines are not safe enough to give it
to children
so
you know
look i i understand that if i say that
out loud
i'm the witch
i get it on the other hand what kind of
person would i be if i didn't say it out
loud it's too clear the evidence is
clear where are the children the healthy
children who have been killed by covid
right
yeah it's it's like incredibly
improbable it's just very very very even
on the cdc's own estimate which i think
is a poor estimate what is it one child
for every every million vaccinated might
be saved that is their estimate right
and and when when there has been a
search for cases in with in which
healthy children have died of covid
literally they have not been found so
again we could have instances in which a
child has comorbidities that change the
the cost-benefit analysis but if your
child is a normal healthy child
then
you have to ask yourself am i doing this
for their benefit or am i doing it for
somebody else's benefit and who's
right or am i just doing it because i'm
afraid or because what what i think it's
going to happen a lot is the poor are
going to be hurt if i can put it this
way okay i gotta work my somebody says i
gotta work my husband's gotta work we
can't pay the rent if we don't work my
kid has to be able to go to public
school
and therefore you know because that's
where they go during the day while
mother and father at work they won't let
them go to public school so
i have no choice and that and that that
coercion will fall squarely and heavily
of the people who are not lucky enough
to be able to homeschool or take the
child out or put the child in a separate
private school
yep
all right well i think i want to say one
more thing before we close this out and
then i will let you uh have whatever
last word you want to have but i think i
want to say i know
from experience that this conversation
is going to get me in trouble
yet again
and i want to ask people who think that
that makes sense who think that this
conversation is a problem right and that
somebody who would have this
conversation
needs uh to be held responsible as the
the current vernacular
i want you to think
about what kind of society it is in
which this conversation is one that
isn't allowed to be had
you're talking about a conversation
between
two doctors of philosophy about
questions of human health about our
responsibilities to each other about the
responsibilities of those who govern us
to the citizenry
this is a conversation that needs to be
had and to the extent that you are
scandalized by us having it by a person
who believes they have been
injured a person who is more than
qualified to evaluate the likelihood
that that is simply a mere coincidence
versus the likelihood that there is a
causal relationship between the vaccine
that she took and the injury that she
has experienced
if you believe that this conversation is
irresponsible
then i would ask you to look at yourself
in the mirror and say what kind of
society are you building if you're going
to rule out a conversation like this
even if there are elements of this
conversation that are wrong
i know that i have attempted to be
responsible in this conversation i can
tell that you are attempting to be
responsible and the fact is
if you can't handle the content of this
conversation i believe that's on you
all right
lydia mcgrew what would you like to uh
to close us out with
wow that was so good brett i don't i
don't know if i could if i could better
that actually because that what i
thought of while you were talking there
was
being much younger you and i are
probably of a similar age these are the
kind of conversations we had all the
time in graduate school right you'd have
you have people who disagreed
very strongly about the role of
government uh you know you'd have your
libertarian over here and you'd have
your uh conservative over here and
you're liberal over here and your
anarchist or whatever and you know and
you just sit around you sit up till the
middle of the night debating these
things because we were young and it was
fun you know and it was considered that
this is part of living in a free country
and um no we weren't publishing them and
putting them on youtube because there
was no youtube but that's not the point
it never would have occurred to us to
say
that this is a dangerous thing for
people to overhear such conversations
should not be dangerous for people to
overhear among a free people so that a
free people can
can think and can listen to these
conversations and then can just ponder
these things and can vote in an informed
manner for the rulers and uh and for
their rules and so
that is confirming what you're saying
just taking me back to the days of my
youth when we used to have these
arguments all the time
let's continue having them because
that's really important
absolutely um i am reminded that it
wasn't so long ago that we could have
vigorous disagreements with each other
and not uh assume that it was a you know
collapse of morality in the other person
that was responsible for them having a
different perspective right right
absolutely all right well lydia mcgrew
i really appreciate your willingness to
put your story into public so that we
can all grapple with its meaning and
think about what it implies about our
collective
predicament
and i really appreciate the
care you've put into thinking about this
issue and
all i can say is
i can't really know what it is that
you're going through
but
um i can try and i can appreciate how
frightening and frustrating it must be
and
i
i wish you the best of luck in finding
medical professionals who are willing to
listen and to do what medical
professionals are supposed to do to
responsibly experiment and find
treatments for you and i hope that your
immune system figures itself out and
corrects the problem
right
thank you i i appreciate that brett and
i appreciate you taking these risks
because uh without people like you who
are willing to take risks that you
should not have to take um information
would be stifled stifled even further
and so
keep going keep doing that i appreciate
it all right well thanks so much be well
everyone see you next time
you